aquí tenemos una configuración
interesante tengo un campo magnético que
es constante y sale directamente de la
superficie formada por este anillo la
magnitud del campo magnético en
cualquier punto de esta superficie es ve
y lo interesante de aquí es que en la
parte derecha de este circuito o anillo
que tenemos se puede mover pueden
imaginarse que es un cilindro que puede
girar hacia la derecha la magnitud de su
velocidad vamos a llamarla v minúscula y
este cilindro tiene una longitud de
tamaño l
con esta configuración podemos darnos
cuenta de que vamos a tener un cambio en
el flujo magnético porque vamos a tener
este cambio porque vamos a tener este
cambio de campo magnético a través de la
superficie pues porque si esta barra la
podemos mover hacia la derecha y la
movemos a la derecha con una velocidad v
aún cuando el campo magnético en sí
mismo es constante con esto vamos a
estar cambiando el área el área
contenida por este circuito y esto nos
va a dar un cambio en el flujo y siempre
que tengamos un cambio en el flujo nos
va a inducir una fuerza electromotriz o
un voltaje en este circuito que a su vez
ocasionará que haya un flujo de
corriente
ahora pensemos cuál va a ser esta fuerza
electromotriz inducida y vamos a
reescribir la ley de faraday aquí que es
menos n por el cambio en el flujo entre
el cambio en el tiempo
n se refiere al número de circuitos que
tenemos en este caso n va a ser igual a
y el signo negativo el cual ya me he
quejado en vídeos anteriores simplemente
sirve para recordarnos usar las
matemáticas correctas cuando no estamos
trabajando con matemáticas de vectores
específicamente es simplemente para
recordarnos que esta fuerza
electromotriz va a ocasionar una
corriente que viajará en este circuito y
cuyo campo magnético inducido por esta
corriente va a ir en la dirección
opuesta de nuestro cambio en el flujo
así que realmente lo que aquí nos
interesa es el cambio del flujo entre el
cambio en el tiempo que va a ser igual a
esto bueno aquí vamos a escribir el
cambio en el flujo y va a estar dividido
entre el cambio en el tiempo
bueno en este caso nuestro cambio en el
flujo va a ser igual al cambio en la
magnitud de nuestro campo magnético que
va a perpendicular a la superficie
multiplicado por el área de nuestra
superficie dividido entre nuestro cambio
en el tiempo esto que va a ser igual
bueno es constante no va a cambiar en el
tiempo así que el cambio en b va a ser
igual a b x nuestro cambio en el área y
esto lo dividimos entre el cambio en el
tiempo cuál va a ser nuestro cambio en
el área digamos que hay un cambio en el
tiempo cuál será el cambio en el área
durante este cambio de tiempo digamos
que transcurren unidades de tiempo que
tan lejos se va a mover esta barra
durante del tate ya conocemos la
magnitud de nuestra velocidad si
multiplicamos la magnitud de nuestra
velocidad por el cambio en el tiempo nos
va a dar la distancia así que nuestro
cambio en el área va a ser esta
distancia que viajó la barra
por la longitud de la misma barra así
que nuestro cambio en el área que es
esta que estoy señalando aquí el cambio
en área durante este tiempo va a ser la
distancia que recorre esta barra y noten
que esta barra se está moviendo de
manera perpendicular a la dirección del
campo magnético original esto es algo
importante de notar así que nuestro
cambio en área va a ser esta distancia
multiplicado por la longitud de la barra
que es l
esto es nuestro cambio en el área y
podemos sustituir esto en nuestra
fórmula de aquí arriba
esto va a ser igual a nuestra vez aquí
abajo tenemos el cambio en el tiempo y
dijimos que nuestro cambio en el área es
y permítanme reacomodarlo de esta manera
va a ser igual a la longitud de nuestra
barra multiplicado por la magnitud de
nuestra velocidad multiplicado por el
cambio en el tiempo bueno el cambio en
el tiempo de aquí arriba se cancela con
el cambio en el tiempo de aquí abajo así
que el cambio de flujo en este cambio en
el tiempo o el promedio la tasa de
cambio de flujo se simplifica como la
longitud de nuestra barra multiplicado
por la magnitud de la velocidad a la que
se está moviendo esta barra multiplicada
por la magnitud de nuestro campo
magnético el cual es perpendicular a la
superficie y esta fórmula se le van a
encontrar varias veces en sus clases de
física toda esta noción de si tenemos
una barra que se mueve en una dirección
perpendicular al campo magnético va a
inducir una fuerza electromotriz
l por b dl por v por b así que esta
fórmula sale directamente de la ley de
faraday y ustedes pueden decirme bueno
si esto es lo que está ocurriendo cuál
va a ser la dirección en la que se va a
mover esta corriente bueno si el campo
magnético no está cambiando sino que es
el área a la que está aumentando el
flujo va a aumentar con dirección hacia
arriba así que podemos decir que el
flujo se incrementa en esta dirección
por lo que la magnitud de la corriente
inducida va a estar en función de qué
tanta resistencia tenemos aquí pero la
corriente va a inducir un campo
magnético que va en sentido contrario al
cambio en el flujo así que si la
corriente fuera en esta dirección
qué va a pasar pues aplicó la regla de
la mano derecha aquí voy a tener mi
pulgar señalando la dirección de la
corriente y si cierro mis dedos estos
van a señalar la dirección del campo
magnético inducido por esta corriente y
si esto fuera en esta dirección el campo
magnético inducido tendría la misma
dirección que el campo magnético
original se agregaría a este lo que
aumentaría el cambio en el flujo que
está pasando por aquí y ya habíamos
mencionado que esto violaría la ley de
la conservación de la energía así que la
corriente tiene que ir en la dirección
contraria y en este caso va a ir en
sentido horario
recuerden que la corriente me va a
inducir un campo magnético si yo en este
sentido aplico mi regla de la mano
derecha el campo magnético inducido por
esta corriente va a ir en dirección
opuesta al cambio de flujo recuerden que
estamos analizando esta área si esta
área aumenta nuestro cambiará el flujo
también va a aumentar vamos a tener una
mayor cantidad de campo magnético que va
hacia arriba que está contenido en esta
área
así que el campo magnético inducido por
la corriente inducida tiene que ir en el
sentido opuesto a este aumento en el
flujo
así que en este caso la corriente tiene
que ir en sentido horario